>> Sachs:
My name's Eric Sachs.
I'm gonna be speaking
at the Google I/O conference
this year
about some identity standards,
especially in the enterprise.
What I'm gonna focus on
is that Web 2.0 mashups,
as they've gotten more popular--
they've been fun,
but they mostly are designed
to mash up public data--
Google Maps, government data,
et cetera.
And in this session
we're gonna be talking about
security and identity standards
to enable secure mashups,
especially
in some enterprise settings.
They're a whole mix of,
you know, different standards.
Figuring out
what to use when is hard--
OpenID, SAML,
OAuth, OpenSocial,
strong auth,
portable contacts.
More all the time.
So in the first section
of this talk,
we're gonna talk about
Federated Login
and some of the standards
in that space
such as SAML and OpenID.
In particularly, though,
we're gonna focus on
how some of the Software
as a Service vendors
are leveraging this technology
to improve the experience
they offer enterprises,
and in addition,
we're also gonna focus
on some new trends
to make it easier
for small and medium businesses
to use this type of
federation login technology
that in the past was
more really just
for the large enterprises
who could afford
the complex deployments.
Then, in the second
section of this talk,
we're gonna move on
and talk about
how can you mash up
these applications
running on different
Software as a Service vendors,
or to make it even more complex,
you know, what if there's
some code that you've written
that's running on top
of a platform
as a service vendor,
such as Amazon Web Services,
Azure, Google App Engine,
et cetera?
You may even want to combine
something running on those
with a web service
running behind your firewall.
So this type of cross-platform
web service integration
is an area where we're seeing
a lot of consternation
and questions
about best practices.
Again, my name's Eric Sachs.
I'm gonna be
at Google I/O 2009 in May,
and I look forward
to seeing you there.
Thanks.